Unreal Motion Graphics, or UMG for short, is Unreal Engine 5's tool for creating user
interfaces.
Unlike some of Unreal Engine's other tools, this tool actually features two tools in one.
UMG contains a designer and a graph, and the designer is responsible for designing the
look and feel of your UI, while the graph is responsible for the functionality of your
UI.
Let's go ahead and pop over to the Engine now and take a look at this in more detail.
So first off, we need to actually create a user interface blueprint.
So to do that, we're going to hit Control Space, and then from the Content Browser,
we're going to right-click, and underneath User Interfaces, we're going to look for a
Widget Blueprint.
Now when we do that, we are going to be asked to pick parent class, and what we're going
to do is from Common, we're just going to select a user widget.
I'm going to call this Widget Blueprint underscore example.
Now let's double-click on this to open it up, and when we do, it's going to open it up
in the UMG Editor with the Designer tab open.
Now remember, there is a designer and there is a graph, so the designer is how we're going
to make this UMG look, and the graph is how we're going to make this UMG functional.
So let's take a look at the Designer tab first, and then we will go over to the Graph tab.
So across the top, though, we have our File, Edit, Asset, View, Debug, Window, Tools, and
Help, much like we have in all of our other editors.
Then we have our main toolbar, and this is actually going to look pretty similar to the
main toolbar inside of Blueprints.
We have Save and Browse to this asset in the Content Browser.
We have our Compile.
We also have a Diff.
What this does is, if we're using Source Control, this allows us to compare two different Widget
Blueprints to see why they are different or what was changed or if something's broken,
we can see what happened and why it became broken.
This here allows us to start a play in our active viewport if we're trying to debug our
UI, and we need to look at our time or something like that.
This will allow us to just quickly do that from inside of here.
No debug object selected option is actually how we select the debug.
What we would do is when we play and call this UI widget, we would see its name up here
and be able to select it.
The Widget Reflector is a great tool for diagnosing live widgets.
Say we run into an issue with a widget, and the only way to actually look at that issue
is during the game when things are running, because maybe it's spawned off of something
else.
We would use the Widget Reflector to help us diagnose those problems for widgets that are
possibly spawned by other widgets or things that are happening while the project is running
that are kind of hard to see inside of this editor.
Then we have our palette and our library.
Our library contains all of our various things for like a check mark box or an image or something
like that.
We would actually use the library that much unless you are adding some custom content.
The palette on the other hand is where you're going to spend a majority of your time.
This is where we're going to find a lot of the functionality for our UI.
The first thing we need to do here though is add a Canvas panel.
I'm going to add that down here to our hierarchy.
That's going to add me a UI that can be stretched across an entire screen.
Pro tip, if you grab this little handle right here, you'll be able to stretch the UI to
various resolutions to see how it's going to look when it's set from 1280 by 720 to
1136 by 640.
There are a lot of different things inside of here.
I'm not going to go through all of them.
I highly suggest that you go through and experiment.
To work with this stuff, all you simply need to do is just drag what you want from the
palette there down to our hierarchy.
Our hierarchy is going to show us the hierarchy of where things are placed inside of this
UI.
I can also take things and I can have them independent from one another or I can have
them as a child of something else.
That's some really cool things that I can do.
Then we have our details panel.
Much like the details panel in many of the other editors, it's going to be context sensitive
based off of what I have selected.
You can see here when I select my whole UI, we get some different interactions over here
than when I select the canvas panel versus the button.
Speaking of the button, when we want to do something like have this button say be clickable,
we will select that button and then over in the details panel under events, we have all
of these various events.
The cool thing about it is if we bring in something like a check mark box or maybe we
bring in an analog slider.
With those selected and we come down to the events, notice we have the analog on analog
capture or on mouse capture begin, on mouse capture end.
What's really cool about this, I'm just like the button for easiness, but I'm going to
click this on click and what it's going to do is it's going to change me over to the
graph.
Notice I'm in something that looks kind of like blueprints and that's because the UMG
designer or I should say UMG itself is broken up into a designer and a graph.
So the designers, how we make things pretty and the graph is how we make things functional.
So on clicked, now I can pull off of this and do something like print and I could do
a print string.
So when we press that button, we are going to print this hello a couple of things to
note from the graph here.
If I come over here to my blueprint, notice I'm going to have like my pre construct, my
events are up here.
I have functions and macros that I can look at or override.
Here is my variables so I can add variables much like I can in normal blueprints and then
I will get the details panel here will contain the various details if there is something
that has details that I can use.
Go ahead and compile and save that.
Now you do need to set up UMG render widgets to be rendered to the screen, which is a little
bit outside the scope of this, but trust in that this is a simple process and that UMG
can be used to create any type of UI no matter what type of project you are creating.